it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we reveal the stories
behind the headlines
for that we turn to fox news contributor
raymond arroyo
uh ray last month wasn't a cnn media
reporter
suggesting that cable distributors
should basically adopt standards to
screen content
on networks like fox news right so now
brian stelter is getting in on the act
while some cry cancel culture let me
suggest a different way to think about
this
a harm reduction model reducing a liar's
reach
is not the same as censoring freedom of
speech freedom of speech is different
than freedom of
reach and algorithmic reach is part of
the problem
freedom of reach what stelter is saying
there laura
is you can have your speech but your
ability to disseminate it
could be restricted depending on his
ability
to determine whether or not you're a
liar okay with all due respect
who died and made brian stelter the
commissar of news
in the world i mean this man who god
love him
has never reported a thing in his life
he's a media watcher
he went from writing a college blog
about tv to writing about tv at the new
york times
to the cnn gig he watches tv that's his
experience
without cnn stelter's reach would extend
all the way to a bag of chips
and a diet coke at the end table because
he would be at home watching tv that's
what he does
it's a very strange idea of what the
media should be laura
all right well the most ridiculous thing
here is that
this idea that they're they're the
keepers
of the truth and anyone who reports
differently
is instantly a liar or a white
supremacist or pick your poison
well and they want to they want to
screen up but one outlet that cut
major outlet that contradicts or might
report
extension of facts and the continuation
of things they don't wish to cover
for instance i read this in the new york
times covering biden
of 20 factual claims all but three were
largely if not
completely accurate well laura they
failed to mention biden promising
georgia voters
two thousand dollar checks that's not
happening he's not even asking for it
and then he promised there would be no
end to fracking
he wouldn't ban fracking the moment he
got behind the resolute desk
he signed an executive order and
surprise he banned fracking
it's a tragedy and i think we're both in
agreement
more reporting laura is better than less
that's the answer
and look i'll defend even cnn's right to
be seen
despite their pornographic tendencies
the senate impeachment trial of the
former president of the united states
who has been impeached for inciting the
erection
inciting the insurrection at the u.s
capitol
let the audience decide i say laura let
the audience decide
reporters are not the only ones
misspeaking vice president kamala harris
hit local media in west virginia to try
to pressure senator joe manchin
to support the administration's 1.9
trillion dollar stimulus package now
here's her plan for those out-of-work
coal miners very interesting
all of those skilled workers who are in
the coal industry
and and and transferring those skills to
what we need to do
in terms of dealing with reclaiming
abandoned
landmines set off those abandoned land
mines let them go out there
let those coal miners blow themselves up
does she even realize how insensitive
this sounds
can you imagine telling laid off
reporters why don't you trade change
careers
go become a realtor you can sell off all
those abandoned newsrooms that'll work
for you something they always say
they always say just you know retool
your skills go to a skills
workshop and everything will be fine now
mansion i saw he's really
not happy with kamala's media tour in
his state or apparently the political
pressure
i saw it i couldn't believe it no one
called me we're going to try to find a
bipartisan pathway for it i think we
need to
but we need to work together that's not
a way of working together
well what is he going to do about it is
this the call
is this about biden's calls for unity
even his own party does it make sense
now
well look what it shows you is kamala
harris is to unity
what dr kevorkian is to health care
lawyer this is not going to work they
keep talking about
unity but they're feeding on their own
party to go to west virginia and arizona
i get using the media against the
opposition party but when you've got a
one vote majority in the senate you
better be really nice to those moderates
and they're not
this is the coming crack up in the
democratic party not in the republican
which is all you hear about
in many many places in the media
meanwhile if a democrat gets a cold
it changes the whole balance of power in
the sense
tonight this one's getting quarantined
and it's over
yeah we got we got one senator getting
ingrown toenail removed and then this
whole thing could be thrown out of whack
mcconnell in charge again
exactly raymond thanks so much